and as cancer grew up and turkey came to
this country and wound up in the nba
just a few hours ago he became an
american citizen to mark the occasion he
has legally changed his name his new
name is ennis cantor freedom and this
cancer freedom plays for the boston
celtics and he joins us tonight and
that's mr freedom thank you so much for
joining us congratulations on becoming a
citizen tell us why you've done this why
you've become a citizen and changed your
name
thanks for having mr carlson you know i
think i can just easily say that this is
the greatest day of my life you know it
was my dream the first day first day i
stepped into america and you know after
i get my green card obviously it's been
a rough six years because turkish
government revoked my passport and put
my name on interpol list
but i think you know i wanted to do it
because i remember first time i came to
america you know one of my teammate it
was back in 2009 uh my teammate
criticized the president and i turned
around and i told him i was like dude
what are you doing they're gonna throw
you in a jail and he and he told me he
started laughing and said this is
america don't worry about it you are not
in turkey anymore i was very shocked but
uh you know the reason i wanted to do it
because this you know from day one
america gave me a home
american people opened their arm give me
a warm welcome and i wanted to do it
because i wanted to
call somewhere where i can feel like
this is my home now and uh it is the
greatest feeling uh i ever had
oh
that's just wonderful i wish i wish we
had so many more people like you who are
as grateful to be here as you clearly
are um how have your teammates responded
do you think they're as grateful to be
americans as you are
i mean my teammates actually you know
were really happy for me because they
knew the struggle that i had the last
you know six years uh you know it was a
funny joke in the beginning because they
were calling me mr freedom and now it
became a reality but uh i think my
teammates were like
the
the one that you know was my like my
brothers you know um
it was just so amazing because their
support gives me so much hope and
motivation to fight and fight for what's
right so i definitely give a lot of
credit to my teammates
it seems like people who move here from
countries that are not free appreciate
the freedoms here much more than a lot
of us who grew up with those freedoms
does have you noticed that
you know i feel like i'm going to just
say this and i'm going to be honest
people should feel really blessed and
lucky to be in this i'm being be in
america because
you know they love to criticize it but
when you leave a country like turkey or
or you know china or somewhere else you
will appreciate the freedoms you have
here
yes you know
so i feel like they should just please
they they should just keep their mouth
shut and stop criticizing the greatest
nation in the world and they should
focus on you know the their freedoms and
their human rights and their democracy
so this is
america give me everything i have so i i
definitely appreciate the united states
of america
that's how i feel we're putting up a
picture of one of your sneakers on the
screen here tell us what this is what's
what's on there
uh i cannot see the picture right now
but if you tell me what it is i will
tell you this story about it
it says
one says free something my eyes are bad
so free the uyghurs stop genocide
mm-hmm
yes
yep
uh well obviously uh you know
you know someone had to do it i'll be
honest with you there are so many you
know athletes so many actors so many
celebrities out there who are scared
because
if they criticize china obviously they
will be affected you know their
endorsement deals their
contract or their you know their money
will be affected and they're scared to
say anything but to me you know human
rights democracy and freedom is way more
important than everything they can offer
me you know morals values and principles
are the most important thing in life so
to me i wanted to stand up for my muslim
brothers and sisters who are in you know
concentration camps are getting tortured
and raped every day and i don't care
whoever said which organization or which
company i don't care about any of that i
care about to be the voice of all those
innocent people out there who don't have
a voice
if you have any siblings tell them to
come please
and it's freedom
great to see you tonight
amazing hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else